[Musik]
mona vetsch wird das kalte wasser gehört
siehe chronik voi das ist die nation
also grundsätzlich gar nicht immer vom
schlechtesten us anlagen positiv
überraschen
konnte
[Musik]
wie ist das schön
flims auf blauen
aha hat das wichtigste anliegen ich sehe
das so ich hoffe dass ich so eine
sprechende grußkarte
[Gelächter]
weg von
monaco das wirken der op so bildlich vor
sich
von einem und monat
musik
viele menschen fahren
identifiziert
also wenn menschen sowie die bank auf
zurückziehen so irgendwas falsch wäre
[Musik]
sicher das interesse daran ihre oder wie
ich habe beobachtet
was ich das doch sie sind ja vor der
polizei aber sie mit motorfahrzeugen
schlager open schlag
auf
schlag gerät hochkonjunktur quer durch
alle generationen und schichten aber
nicht mit mona vetsch bis jetzt gut
vorbereitet auf alles gefasst das ist
heimatland monat bietet
klar und ab
aber das
muss irgendwo
finanzielle risiko
aber
sehr spitz profanes tour
zu schützen habe ich kein flash beim
aufbau und wieder abbauen und nach
wieder aufsitzen
der
interface bank eigentlich
aufnehmen so sind zum ersten mal
gastgeber vorher ist schlager open air
zehn
jahren andere nach sich ziehen können
einziger eigentlich war über zwanzig
andere destinationen seite haben doch
das sei es wäre also die ränder mix mit
helene fischer ein ticken wir bis über
620 zuschauer kann okay und wir fangen
jetzt aber wieder dahin
zu
stark enstar der
wiese
naja
das mit dir schon erklärt die arme wenn
ihr doch mal fangen
ja also eine mit dem tierschutz mit dem
bild wird auch sicher
das ist okay weil es sich für ihn ist
wichtig dass man jetzt lange dabei sind
also sie hinter ihren rückzugsort ist
klar ich sicher nicht so viel action für
die mobile aber er kann das verdreckte
okay also blieben die schäden wieder
miliz befürchten ein schlager
[Musik]
der berg bebte
der festivals geändert aus team ich
bleibe und
smeets drehen programmchef freddy bruder
der bergweg des festivals und im
backstage-bereich es wirklich so es
kommt nur artist und backstage rhein mit
dieser community vorne schaut dann auch
das muss wirklich klar durchgezogen
werden und das ist sehr sehr wichtig
größer da sich die freddie
neave ersten schlagerfestival
sondern ich mich
haben wir mal einen gang höher und das
jetzt extrem ruhig mir völlig fremde
welt warum schlagen damit schlagen
meiste geld jetzt auch gratis
ganz ehrlich
wenn ich jetzt nicht eigentlich die
position head to head und mir das ufo
habe all den jahren den namen gemacht
hat würde ich nie anfangen
das bringt dich wohl irgendwie zum
herzinfarkt als goldman banker aus kommt
man wirklich mal so dass im schlafwagen
letzte woche dass auch größte tabubruch
kommen 39 wir haben also zum doktor aber
irgendwann andere der abstand widerruf
und danke ich kann es ziemlich haben
eine vision und die vision die erlaubte
einfach wie viel liedmann kommen dass du
mit der schwarze null oder umbuchen
wir werden jetzt sehen wir aktiviert
musik
und wenn es wahr ist georg sind ist dann
das
letzte mal
2000 abbrechen und das mag ich besser
belüftet plan geht es für mich mitten im
dorf ist aber so richtig los ramba samba
party
[Musik]
[Applaus]
er verbindet
[Musik]
vor als stunden lang auf der bank das
ist nicht so
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
schlager ist darum nicht so beliebt bei
jung und alt die wichtigkeit
zurückbringt montag manish verloren
[Musik]
backstage 14 auftritte aufwärmen der
marc robin
320 nachwuchshoffnung vom schweizer
schlager und der sohn vom festival vater
fred rutten
[Musik]
erzählerin
aber dass biblis langsam
[Applaus]
war
das kreischen der
polizei
dort sie durch
leitung mit viel
was ich stromausfall
[Applaus]
der markt sich mit diesem konzept
bringen die schlager typische geste
[Musik]
im publikum sind aus in jede dritte frau
wer der fremde ist ein kritischer
beobachter vor dem schlager singen der
sohn aber hinter 2
mehr
[Musik]
aber ihre mini dosis schlagerhit
karlsruher zwei schlaufen
[Musik]
märkte morgen wohl genügend räume mit
andere helfen dir immelt wegen geld
sondern alle weg ruft
[Musik]
die bonis ins am schluss spurt schlager
familie broderick schon wie ihr sohn
marc robin start des programms
bekräftigen
der ruhige pol in der familie jetzt hat
sie aber glaubt gottes problem
jahrhundert errichtet ohne mikro
und die sind immer natürlicher
und die grüne stadt brauche die haben
die spitzen sollten
die handwerker brauchen
jetzt ist die politik gefragt
nicht verzagen fred die fragen seiner
show brett leeb
[Musik]
wir sind bereit jetzt ratlos go movie
komisch
das kranke herz zahlt die einwände flash
adobe andere mit weg einzige mensch
kann ich an
[Gelächter]
der matthias reim madonna pretoria
[Musik]
während der oberahr langsam auf position
geholt ohne inhalt claudia jung abgrund
dampf und deutsche schlager sie 23
erfolgreich im geschäft dass wir unser
auto
sicher
ich hab ich ja schon alles wieder
jetzt wollte ich so ein vorbildlicher
kleiner chauffeur sei
das machst du nicht noch mal jetzt mache
ich ihnen einfach hier die tür augen
darin sah ich tue so als hätte ich das
nicht dankeschön frauen herzlichen dank
dass von twitter
[Musik]
sei man
ja hallo
ja so ungefähr ich sitze hier neben
einer netten dame im auto und die mich
fährt und wir haben das kamerateam im
nacken was uns filmt und die finden das
glaube ich gerade ganz lustig dass du
anrufst und ho ho ho ho
ja schön ist
[Gelächter]
ok er macht das ja prima tussi danke
toyota
also schöne grüße von meinem mann er
lässt er die unterbrechung entschuldigen
er wollte nur wissen aber noch ein
bisschen was einkaufen soll damit ich
morgen auch was gutes kochen ja ich
hoffe doch so gerne
angerufen um zu sagen jetzt gerade
unterwegs und erfährt jetzt wird er
könnte eigentlich noch so einen schwung
machen und rote paprika kaufen wir essen
für unser leben gern so mit feta käse
gefüllte paprika mein mann ist auch
vegetarier und das ist immer noch der
gleiche mann wieso in den letzten 30
jahren oder haben sie auch so viele
wechsel wie ein paar ihrer kollegen ich
habe ganz häufig gewechselt sind wir 20
jahre
ist es schon eine das darf man schon
fragen oder weil das ist mir aufgefallen
also sinn ja immer alle von liebe und so
überhaupt vorher und ich hab mir
manchmal so ein bisschen vorgestellt
wahrscheinlich müssen die deshalb ihre
freundin so häufig wechseln dass die
noch glaubwürdig so von wohnfläche live
sehen können wir das ist in erster linie
in erster linie ist das ein problem der
männlichen kollegen männer sind ja so
schwach die können ja nicht nein sagen
wohin gehen wir frauen da sehr stark
sein können aber uns fliegen die herzen
zu sonst nichts anderes das ging ist es
einfacher es ist schon mein mann gesehen
der seine unterhose auf die bühne wirft
also ich
aber würden wir
ein anderes denken hundewelpen hundewelt
das wollen wir doch alles gar nicht
weil wir wissen wie wir männer
unterhosen manchmal aussehen können also
ich meine
ich meine rein vom optischen her ist ja
nicht immer ein gewinn
als dann wieder ohne hose besser oder
wie habe ich da sitzen versteht ja dass
unter umständen ist es so ja dann lieber
die ganze wahrheit ohne hose
claudia jung jetzt schon lieblings
vegetarier auf der schlagerbühne
selbstironisch und ziemlich direkt so
hätte ich mir schlagersängerin
vorgestellt
doch ausländische gerbert umstehen ich
mache ich eine wurde lieblingssänger vom
treten
[Musik]
hügel ganz
die beiden verbindet sie die
freundschaft der freddy hat in gehlberg
sogar schon jetzt geschrieben
o
[Musik]
projektile auf knopfdruck herstellen
so schreibt ein business nie verloren
der junge wird komplett begrüßt der
persönliche kontakt zu den stars
signieren der schlüssel ohne dass love
in liegt
[Musik]
nein
hat sie herzlich willkommen baby sucht
die bühne durch claudia jung
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viel eher und muss raus frühstück
schnell aus
jeden tag das kind aus der schule franz
machst du's mit den han
schon die
indem jobs notwendig
märz am telefon
die ganze zeit
[Musik]
ich bin am schafe und warten auf den
markt ist da auf der andy borg
[Musik]
sie können
nicht fahren
[Musik]
ich dachte dass ich dachte wir sind eine
kleine kapsel
wir haben uns geprügelt und ich ach so
ja ich war deswegen
im jahr und
das ganze lieber selber ja ich will
jetzt nicht direkt
am berg hoch aber
nein
und gehört habe das gar nichts zum
abschließen oder sich lieber selber das
auto zu
ich war hier
mit
einer figur kannst du auf jeden fall bei
uns mit
von andy borg und die sind sehr breit
um bis zu zu formulieren eine sache groß
im schlagerbusiness ich mir locker und
unkompliziert der druck hanni busybox in
frau und managerin trifft
zeigt sich lok maschine sind zwei paar
schuhe auch im volkacher
schlagerbusiness gibt es klare grenzen
stark zurückfahren
[Musik]
mai
anders als in
japan
also da ein auto habe ich festgestellt
daher der öffentliche
anlagen ja ja ja wir haben aber diese
schlechte erfahrungen gemacht mit
solchen sachen wo wir haben schon grenze
gezogen das ist unser zuhause im garten
und wenn wir die autotüren zu machen
dann ist das rüber du hast deine frau
auch immer dabei auch spezielle arbeit
ja auch zusammen ja genau aber ich sehe
wie die dann auch mal sagt jetzt mache
ja ja das muss man auch erst lernen
damit umzugehen aber das ist ich möchte
einfach nicht dass diese diesem fall ich
das beschreiben sollte diese aura dieser
so einen künstler umgibt ich möchte mal
vor publikum oder vor dem fernsehteam
nicht wegmachen ganz einfach weil ich
wenn ich hier bin bin ich für die leute
da wenn ich das nicht will muss ich zu
hause bleiben ja trotzdem brauche ich
manchmal jemanden der dann sagen
deine frau die muss manchmal auch ein
bisschen härter sein dass du ja oder
aber die eigenen interessen sie
ermöglicht mir im leben
so wie ich weiß nicht ob das schreiben
soll ich habe mit der schule damals
aufgehört ich bin ein schulkind
geblieben also ich lebe hier
genannten jetzt einige zu haben aber es
ist so die mit mir alles irdische hat
und ich lebe in einer traumwelt und kann
in diese länder ausdenken oder 90 sein
zu den leuten und ich habe mitte mit dem
alltag gar nichts wenn er mit allen
unangenehmen hast du mit alle wohnungen
genehmigen zu tun wie kochen einkaufen
gegen organisierte ja
wo ist das denn mit dem
[Musik]
fernseh auftritt und er weiß genau was
die fans von ihm bank sehe und höre
in österreich
[Gelächter]
hat sich dieses eine jahr schon bezahlt
gemacht
als schlager sein braucht disziplin die
eigene lohn ist es auch nur mit ständig
vom publikum zählt für andy borg
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hoffentlich nicht
ja
[Applaus]
am ende der bühnenprofi prämie wms
publikum von allen sagte
sie haben muss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich muss schon wieder los nicht ums wohl
von matthias reim kümmere viel gibt es
allerdings nichts tue pc-spieler
showroom
alkohol vorkommt das geht bei mir oder
[Musik]
ohne
das ist mein beruf ung spiel parierte
[Applaus]
zwar vor ihm lag am eingang ich habe die
leute wissen gefragt warum kommt ihr her
da kam der junge frau hat mir gesagt
weißt du wer matthias frey
da hab ich gesagt habe du bist ja auch
noch so jungen matthias reim sie seit
sie acht hilfst du bist du ja großer
held das ist hier schon ja
es gibt diesen
menschen die einsam
geschmack
[Musik]
immer wieder und sie das golfen aber ist
das wirklich da teilweise wirklich von
kindesalter
aber warum also ich hab gedacht was hat
diese junge frau mit einem mann der auch
schon einiges mehr an leben hinter sich
gebracht hat was hat die berührt an
deiner musik ich nehme an das ist das
ist einfach die stories deswegen die
geschichte nicht erzählen die sind ja
alterslos naja und selbst ein verdammt
ich lieb dich was vor 27 jahren ist bis
heute einfach das thema ist immer noch
aktuell ja die zerrissenheit bei der
liebe und man weiß nicht ob und nicht
uns ja und man sagt ja dass nicht mehr
aus sich jetzt einen trinken und ohne
selten aber auch nicht aus also das ist
hat sich nicht verändert ich wollte dann
aber ist ja verdammt mühsam dein lied
werden nicht aber du schon wie gehst du
damit um also dieses weiß ein lied mit
ähnlich leben du wahrscheinlich
[Applaus]
wieder hinterlässt
ich hinterlasse einen zum schulischen
somit habe ich auch meinen namen auf
die bergwelt der schweiz gemeistert
wurden ein glas und 2 1 gilt
[Applaus]
matthias reim erhält vom in ihrer jugend
geht es zu
[Applaus]
im programm
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sid
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hab dich lieb ich dich
mag dich
[Applaus]
fertig
[Musik]
lothar
noch lauter
ja
[Applaus]
[Musik]
am nächsten morgen zum glück kein
tinnitus sie die ohren sondern um es
tiefe vor dem release
im petto
die kann man nicht zurückbringen
du und wir sehen
gut doch also
lautet sehr gut parlament sehr viele
heimische joker
dasein der super gemacht
naja aber der stimme langsam steige
der fünfte sich bewusst für schwarze
zahlen buchte die hände geschafft
und wir gott zum frieden bis zum
zusammenbruch für das festival geschafft
hat
morgen
früh wir sind ja
morgen um sechs wochen
ich bin aber wir haben
momentan mit marc brauchen ausgehoben
dann schaut man auch leute die ganz nach
den lautstarken aber gefahren und
technik haben sie aber braucht ist das
gewaltige defizit
er ist nur noch fürs künstlerische
zuständig aber trotzdem ziel erreicht
und
das macht mich persönlich
werde
ein schönes habe ich muss ganz sicher
fühlen uns sehr wohl und ich halte mich
platz gebraucht
also vom videoscreens grad sofort
weitergeht und murmeln brauchen glaubt
auch mehr ruhe
drei minute später erfahre die
werbetrommel gestört es gibt kraft 22
das hat sich einfach nicht gerechnet
aber der frage ob
irgendwo es neues auf baustellen
in der woche dort monique
hütt ist es das asylzentrum und mona
wird domäne 40 rotiert
monats mit drin im durchgangszentrum es
aber zwischen putz amtlich war davon
asylentscheid und es braucht linie
freude im alltag
[Musik]